andre drummond grabbed the rebound he
averaged over 15 a game last year here's
Blake Griffin tried to feed Drummond and
a steal by porzingis the lawn right news
slowed a little bit the beginning at
camp with the hamstring injury but he's
played these first two preseason games
three-point attempts for the other side
of the floor and hammers come down the
floor and score again [ __ ] in the
trail three that's all are both the hits
key Detroit was a playoff team last year
the eighth seed in the East 41 in 41
they were swept in round one by top seed
Milwaukee but three porzingis again a
thing of beauty really because of the
shot stick porzingis is making early we
call him luca with a head of steam
mariana [ __ ] softens up the defense
with a screen looked at drives it finds
right in the corner for a 3-ball chicken
role in the bombing Lucan porzingis and
the floaters get four Luca which he
pulled
oh he just fools everybody and chopped
the float he nutmeg himself he said just
it seemed out there in the system yeah
it's time oh nice crossover oh now that
is something else
whip dock to jump shot down baby girl a
some work on top of the law we're seeing
us with a follow after look up garnet
off on the right foot here in the third
quarter porzingis for the follow dunk
after the lob was off target and the
hands at the lawn right in one of his
toothless water fell he screens for Luca
who drives and lays it in back down work
here for porzingis they come down to the
double into the shot clock look at
reigns it's late clock who does that to
me
- maybe he's locked and loaded knocked
it down let's trust the quarter the
Mavericks went to their bench finishing
a foul is called as well so an
opportunity for three the hard way and
there boom on those good job of changing
the full of the game long three look at
yes sir Robin Lopez was underrated
Marquis could really play the game so
people see it drills a three up top
[Applause]
Lucca crowded by Sterling Brown the
all-time leader in games played in the
community but the screen works out that
loosen up the defense just enough to get
a Lucca that sliver of space straight
down that time step right into that
three after screen by Kleber nothing but
cord and they shoot a lot of perimeter
shots so they're always going to be in
the game you're always gonna have a
chances both on its inside
seeing boban operate inside art has been
very effective because I say we kept him
in front just challenged his shot it was
a tough shot
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
hey see the penetration Luckenbach him
do against Yanis a moment ago he could
guard any kind of player on the
perimeter and as a big
fifteen be honest has 27 in the first
half with a preseason game Lapita bacon
three he has found a special place
unfortunately the only thing that's kind
of slow
is the only thing that can slow down
Luca da judge 55 earlier I said JJ was
that guy because they think not only has
the knowledge but but when he says
something by the way you can pick up
where it left off at the end of the
second quit but they understand but
focus behind the boys saying in winter
saying like my old coach used to say
stop worrying about how I said it and
just worry about what I said to shoot
the ball former recovered there's that
pass that you guys love the moment ago
look of a nifty pass and hold on up over
everyone to catch it finish it these
Memphis's may be that easy then you go
Houston Rockets fitted with two MVPs
former players together teammates
like Christophe right here it needs to
continue to do that Xander to get
anywhere he wants on the floor and I
think is his biggest one of his biggest
asset as a player Luca it's where he
wants to go on the floor down inside it
kicks it out to clean go for it all
good-looking free there by Maxie clima
the tallest two players in the NBA
porzingis and beau bond on the floor for
the map right now let's look at scores
across a foul that's doing whatever you
want get the step backs and get
everything you want but this is going to
get into knock opportunity to get to the
free-throw line a little bit more when
he's close to the basket sensation
offensive rebound leads to a Lucan
three-pointer he's got a three point
play a three o'clock basket now on the
opening minutes for almost two years
right so you gotta do some time to
actually get rid of e not hesitate
though
[Music]
really shoot the basketball we got these
a little pump fake that did come out he
pulled the trigger and knocked it now
and it was nice so the geyser and always
seems to make the right decision at the
open floor wake up there
Gallinari with a 3-1 play a moment ago
has 11 and gilja's Alexander has 6 top
scores for OKC deflected long and still
crammed in by a clay doll
that is really good vision that size by
Luca here's the pass
pick-and-roll last minute Luca made sure
he drew both those guys and forced them
to qualify for the league leaders in per
game steps at per minute steps here is
Luca you could do it all that talk my
dribble to a strong hand just a stop for
the tip point because everything that
he's done is big black
open three bullsááá
[Applause]
Lucas drawing two people with the
backpack various basically goes inside
to Noel putting down low good hands by
Luca he was the first player that
dislodged the ball then porzingis helped
out enforcing that turnover as well
right 4:30 yes sir to start the
preseason in the back to back last week
your choice
[Music]
Jen's porzingis in the aftermath there
he is going up top Luca finds porzingis
okay
porzingis rashaam it shot was off the
rim here's Daanish again who could dodge
unloads yes three
[Applause]
[Music]
big porzingis try another
[Applause]
somehow that doesn't go
and the interior presence of this man
porzingis to the basket
we'll go to the line and how about those
last 30 scheme with the Mavs and how
about the unicorn just running the floor
great job of getting down Brunson
dropping it off for something they said
something really profound to you it's
great to have both my teas
[Applause]
yes kristaps porzingis welcome back the
corn fly JJ Barea with that South touch
that ball just hangs around the rim and
you're looking for singers right now
even against Harold constantly moves
from his letting it fly four and a half
to go before half-time gotcha
on Kauai why with a hand that clawed his
face and dodged it still makes it go
and what does Kauai do to players he
bullies them he uses a size and muscle
look at no no issue there a Dodger to
the end the great you know the ball fake
and that chance to put the ball on the
floor clipper team that's made some
serious changes 48 and 34 last year and
what guy hasn't changed a bit since the
first half is dodged started by a
Canadian there Kevin Gallagher
actually no I'm sorry Patrick Patterson
we haven't seen Leon do common Galli yet
Daanish they post double team comes
porzingis knocks it down
Christoph's porzingis past the midway
point of the third quarter and he ready
for the regular season opener against
the lakers porzingis spins all
[Applause]
what's up you guys this Taylor Brooks
with bleacher report make sure that you
subscribe for some more video content